I'm already forgetting that you're not
real like this really so novel it's this
is just a an avatar version of me but
that's a deep philosophical question yes
but I mean but here's some of the so I
put this on this morning and I was like
all right like it's like okay this my
hair is a little shorter in this than my
physical hair is right now I probably
need to go get a haircut um and like I I
actually I did happen to shave this
morning but but if I hadn't you know I
could still have this photorealistic
Avatar that is that is more cleanly
shaven right even if I'm you know a few
days in um physically so I do think that
there are going to start to be these
subtle questions that seep in where the
the Avatar is realistic um in in the
sense of this is kind of what you looked
like at the time of capture but it's not
necessarily temporarily accurate to
exactly what you look like in this
moment and though they're going to end
up being um a bunch of
questions that come from that over time
that I think are going to be fascinating
too you mean just like the nature of
identity of who we are are we the people
you know how people do like like summer
beach body with people be for the scan
they'll try to loose some weight and
look their best and sexiest with the
nice hair and everything like that I it
does um it does raise the question of
you know if a lot of people interacting
with the digital version of ourselves
who are we really are we the The Entity
driving the Avatar or are we the Avatar
well I mean I think our physical bodies
also fluctuate and change over time too
so I think there's a similar question of
like which version of that are we right
there's there's like the I mean it's and
it's interesting identity question
because all right it's like I don't know
it's like weight fluctuates or or things
like that it's like I I think most
people don't tend to think of themselves
as the I don't know it's an interesting
psychological question some maybe some
people maybe a lot of people do think
about themselves as the kind of worst
version um but you know but I think a
lot of people probably think about
themselves the best version and and I
and then it's like what you are on a
day-to-day basis doesn't necessarily map
to to um to either of those so I that
that's yeah there will definitely be a
bunch of a bunch of social scientists
and and folks will have to you know and
and psychologists are
really there's going to be a lot to
understand about how our perception of
ourselves and others um is shifted from
this well this might be a bit of a
complicated and a dark question but one
of the first feelings I had experiencing
this is I would love to talk to loved
ones and the next question I have is I
would love to talk to people who are no
longer here that are loved ones so like
if you look into the future is that
something you think about who people who
pass away but they can still exist in
the metaverse you can still have you
know talk to your father talk to your
grandfather and grandmother and and
mother once they pass away the power of
that experience is one of the first
things my mind jumped to because it's
like this is so
real yeah I think that there are a lot
of norms and things that people have to
figure out around that there's probably
some balance where you know if someone
is has lost a loved one and is grieving
there there may
be ways in which you know being able to
interact or relive certain memories
could be helpful but then there's also
probably an extent to which it it could
become unhealthy and I mean I I'm not an
expert in that so I think we'd have to
study that and and understand it in more
detail we have you know a fair amount of
experience with how to handle death and
identity and people's digital content
through social media already
unfortunately right where you know
there's um you know unfortunately you
know people who use our services die
every day and their families you know
often want to have access to their
profiles and we have whole protocols
that we go through where you there's
certain parts of it that um that we try
to mem moralize so that way the the
family can can get access to it so that
way the account doesn't just go away
immediately but then there are other
things that are you know important kind
of private things that that person has
like we're not going to give the family
access to someone's messages you know
for example so so um so yeah I think
that there's there's some best practices
I think from the current digital world
that will carry over but um but yeah I
think that this will enable some
different things another version of this
is is is how this intersects with AIS
right because I me one of the the things
that that we're really focused on is you
know we we want there to we want the
world to evolve in a way where there
isn't like a single AI super
intelligence but where you know a lot of
of people are empowered by having AI
tools to to do their jobs and you know
make their lives better and if you're a
Creator right and or if you run a you
know podcast like you do then you know
you have a big community of people who
are super interested to talk to you I
know you'd love to you know cultivate
that community and you interact with
them online outside of the the podcast
as well but I mean there's way more
demand both to interact with you and
that I'm sure you'd love to interact
with the community anymore but you just
are limited by the number of hours in
the day so you know at some point I
think making it so that you could build
um an AI version of yourself that could
interact with people you know not after
you die but but while you're here to
help um you know help help people kind
of fulfill this desire to to interact
with you and your desire to build a
community and there's a a lot of
interesting questions around that um and
you know that's obviously it's not just
in in the metaph IE I think you know we
we'd want to make that work you know
across all the messaging platforms you
know WhatsApp and messenger and
Instagram Direct but you know there's
certainly you know a version of that
where if you could have an avatar
version of yourself in the metaverse
that people can interact with and you
could Define that sort of an AI um
version where you know people know that
they're interacting with an AI that it's
not you know the the the kind of
physical version of you but maybe that
AI even if they know it's an AI is the
next best thing because they they're
probably not going to you know
necessarily all get to interact with you
um directly I I I think that that could
be a really compelling experience there
there's a lot of things that we need to
get right about it um that you know it's
we're not ready to release the the
version that a Creator can can kind of
build a version of themselves yet but
we're starting to experiment with it in
terms of releasing a number of AIS that
people can interact with in different
ways um and I I think that that is is
also just going to be a very powerful um
you know set of capabilities that people
have over time time so you've made major
strides in developing these early AI
personalities um with the idea where you
can talk to them Across The Meta apps
and have like interesting Unique Kind of
conversations what can you describe your
vision there in these early strides and
what are some technical challenges there
yeah so I mean a lot of the vision comes
from this idea that you I I don't I
don't think we necessarily want there to
be like one big super intelligence we
want to empower everyone to both you
have more fun accomplish their business
goals you know just everything that that
they're trying to do and you know we
don't tend to have you know one person
that we work with on everything and I
don't think in the future we're going to
have you know one AI that we work with I
think you're going to want a um a
variety of these um so there are a bunch
of different uses um you know some will
be kind of more assistant oriented
there's a sort of the kind of play
simple one that we that we're building
is called just meta AI it's simple it
you can chat with it in any of your
threads um it doesn't have a face right
it's it's just it's um it's just kind of
more vanilla and and neutral and and
kind of factual um but it could help you
with a bunch of stuff then there are a
bunch of cases that are more kind of
business oriented so let's say you want
to contact a a small business um you
know similarly you know that business
probably doesn't want to have to staff
someone to man the phones and you
probably don't want to wait on the phone
to talk to someone but you're having
someone who you can just like talk to in
a natural way who can you know help you
if you're having an issue with a product
or you if you want to make a reservation
or if you want to you want to buy
something online um having the ability
to to do that and have a natural
conversation rather than navigate some
website or have to call someone and wait
on hold um things it's going to be
really good both for the businesses and
for for normal people who want to
interact with businesses so I think
stuff like that makes sense
um then there are going to be a bunch of
use cases that I think are just fun
right so I think people are going to I
know there will be AIS that like can
tell jokes you can put them into chat
thread with friends I me I think a lot
of this because we're like a social
company right I mean we're we're you
know fundamentally around helping people
connect in different ways and part of
what I'm what I'm excited about is you
how do you enable these kind of AIS to
facilitate connection between two people
or more and put the in a group chat you
know make the group chat more
interesting um around whatever your
interests are sports fashion um Trivia
video games I love the idea of of
playing I think you mentioned balers
gate an incredible game just having an
AI that you play together with and you I
mean that could that seems like a small
thing but it could deeply enrich the
like gaming experience I do think that
AI will be will make the NPCs a lot
better in games too so so that's a a
separate thing that I'm pretty excited
about but um but yeah I mean one of the
one of the AIS that we've built that
just in our internal testing people love
the most is like a like a adventure text
based um G like a dungeon master um nice
and and I I think um you know part of
what what has been fun we we talked
about this a bit but we we've gotten
some like real kind of cultural figures
to play a bunch of these folks and be
the ENT in the Avatar of them so um so
Snoop Dog is the dungeon master which I
think is just hilarious in terms of the
next steps of you know if you meent you
mentioned Snoop to create a snoop AI so
basically AI personality replica a copy
or not a copy maybe um inspired by Snoop
what are the some of the technical
challenges of that what does that
experience look like for Snoop to be
able to create that a so starting off
creating new
personas is easier because it doesn't
need
to stick exactly to what you know that
physical person would want how they'd
want to be represented right it's like
it's just a new character that we
created so even though so Snoop in that
cases you know he's um you know he's
basically an actor right he's playing
the the dungeon master but it's not
Snoop Dogg right it's it's um you know
whoever the the dungeon master is um if
you want to actually make it so that you
have an AI embod
a real
Creator there's a whole set of things
that you need to do to make sure that
that AI is not going to say things that
the creator doesn't want right and um
and that the AI is going to you know
know things and be able to represent
things in the way that the Creator would
want the way that the Creator would know
um so I think that it's less of a it's
less of a question around like having
the Avatar Express them I mean that that
I think where you know it's like well we
have our kind of V1 of that that we'll
release soon um is after connect but you
know that'll get better over time but a
lot of this is really just about
continuing to make the the models for
these AIS so that they're just more and
more I don't know you could say like
reliable or predictable in terms of what
they'll communicate that way you know
when you want to create the Lex um
assistant AI that that your community
can talk to um you can you know it's you
don't program them like normal computers
you're training them they're AI models
not not not um kind of normal computer
programs but um but you want to get it
to be predictable enough so that way you
can set some parameters for it and even
if it isn't perfect all the time um you
want it to generally be able to stay
within those bound so that's a lot of um
what what I think we need to nail for
for the creat cre that's why that one's
actually a much harder problem I think
than starting with with uh with new
characters that you're creating from
scratch so that one I think will
probably um start releasing sometime
next year um not this year but
experimenting with existing characters
and the assistant and games and a bunch
of different personalities and
experimenting with some small businesses
um I think that that stuff will'll be
ready to do this year and we're rolling
it out you know basically right after
connect yeah I'm deeply entertained by
the possibility of me sitting down with
myself and saying hey man like you need
to stop the dad jokes or or whatever the
idea of a podcast between you and AI
assistant Lex
podcast I mean there is uh just even the
experience of a codic avatar being able
to freeze yourself like basically first
mimic yourself so everything you do you
get to see yourself do it that's a
surreal experience that feels like uh if
I was like an ape looking in a mirror
for the first time realizing like oh
that's you but then freezing that and
being able to look around like I'm
looking at you it's it's a I don't know
how to put it into words but it just
feels like a fundamentally new
experience like I'm seeing maybe color
for the first time I'm seeing I'm
experiencing a
new way of seeing the world for the
first time because it's physical reality
but it's digital
like and realizing that that's possible
is just it's it's it's blowing my mind
it's just really exciting CU like I
lived most of my life you know before
the internet and and and experiencing
the internet experiencing voice
communication and video communication
you think like well there's a ceiling to
this but this is making me feel like oh
there might not be there might be that
blend of physical reality and digital
reality that's actually what the future
is yeah I think it's a weird experience
it's it feels like the early days of of
like a totally new way of living and
like there's a lot of people that kind
of complain well you know the internet
is not that's not reality you need to
turn all that off and go you know in
nature but this feels like this will
make those people happy I feel like
because it feels real the flaws and
everything yeah well I mean a big part
of how we're trying to design this these
new Computing products is that they
should be physical right I think part
that's a big part of the issue with
computers and TVs and even phones is
like yeah I mean maybe you can interact
with them in different places but
they're they're fundamentally like
you're sitting you're you're still and I
mean people are just not meant to be
that way I mean I think you and I have
this shared passion for for sports and
martial arts and doing stuff like that
we we're just moving around it's like so
much of what makes us people is like you
you move around you're not we're not
just like a brain and a Time right it's
the where you know The Human Experience
is a physical one and um so it's it's
not just about having the immersive
expression of the digital world it's
about being able to really natively
bring that together and and I do really
think that the the real world is this
mix of the physical and the digital
right the digital is there's too much
digital at this point for it to just be
siloed to a small screen but the
physical is too important so you don't
want to just sit down all day long um at
a desk so I I think that this is uh yeah
I do think that this is the future this
is I think the kind of philosophical way
that I would want the world to work in
the future is a much more coherently
Blended physical and digital world there
might be some difficult philosophical
and even ethical questions we have to
figure out as a society uh maybe you can
comment on this so the the meterse seems
to
enable sort of unlock a lot of
experiences that we don't have in the
physical world and the question is like
what is and isn't allowed in the
metaverse you know in video games we
allow uh all kinds of crazy
stuff and in physical reality you know a
lot of that is illegal so where's that
line where's that gray area between
video game and physical reality do you
have a sense of that well I think I mean
there there are content policies and
things like that right in terms of what
what people are allowed to create but I
mean a lot of the rules around physical
I think you try to have a society that
is as free as possible meaning that
people can do as much of what they want
unless you're going to do damage to
other people and and infringe on on
their rights and the idea of damage is
somewhat different in a in a digital
environment I mean when I get into you
know some world with my friends the the
first thing we start doing is shooting
each other which obviously we would not
do in the physical world because you
need hurt each other um but in in a game
that's like just it's almost you know
it's like just fun and um I even in like
the lobby of a game right it's like it
just it's not even bearing on the game
it's just kind of like a funny um sort
of humorous thing to do so it's like is
that is that problematic I don't think
so because it's it's fundamentally it's
not you're not causing harm in that
world so I think that the um part of the
question that I think we need to figure
out is what are the ways where things
could have been harmful in the physical
world that we will now be freed from
that and therefore there should be fewer
restrictions in the Digital World um and
then there might be new ways in which
there could be harm in the digital world
that there weren't the case before so
there's more anonymity right it's um you
know when you when you show up to a you
know a restaurant or something it's like
all the Norms where you you pay the bill
at the end it's because you know you you
have you have one identity and you know
the you know if you if you stiff them
then like you know life is a repeat game
and and that's not going to work out
well for you but you in a digital world
where you can be anonymous and show up
in in different ways um I think the
incentive to act like a good citizen can
be a lot less and that causes a lot of
issues and toxic Behavior so that needs
to get sorted out um so I think in terms
of what is allowed I think you want to
just look at what what what are the the
damages but then there's also other
things that are not related to kind of
harm you know less about what should be
allowed and more about what will be
possible but are more about the laws of
physics right it's like if you wanted to
travel to see me in person you'd have to
get on a plane and and that would like
you know take a few hours to get here
whereas you know we could just jump in a
conference room and you know put on
these headsets and we basically
teleported into a space where we're you
know it feels like we're together so
that's a very novel experience that um
that it it breaks down some things that
previously would have defi the laws of
physics for what it would take to get
together and I think that that will
create a lot of new opportunities right
so um and one of the things that I'm
curious about is there are all these
debates right now about you remote work
or people being together and you I think
this gets us a lot closer to being able
to work physically in different places
but actually have it feel like we're
together um so you know I think that the
the dream is that is that people will
one day be able to just work wherever
they want uh but we'll have all the same
opportunities because you'll be able to
feel like you're physically together I
think we're not there today with with um
with just video conferencing and the
basic technologies that we have but I
think part of the idea is that with
something like this over time you could
get closer to that and that would open
up a lot of opportunities right because
then people could live physically where
they want while still being able to get
the benefits of being physically or or
kind of feeling like you're together um
with people at work all the ways that
that helps to build more culture and
build better relationships and build
trust um which think are real issues
that if if you're not seeing people you
know in in in person ever so yeah I
don't know I think it's going to be it's
very hard from first principles to think
about all the implications of um of of a
technology like this and you know all
the good and and and the things that you
need to mitigate so you you try to do
your best to to kind of Envision what
things are going to be like and
accentuate the things that that are
going to be awesome and hopefully
mitigate some of the the the downside
things but I you know it's the reality
is that we're going to be building this
out one year at a time it's going to
take a while um so we're going to just
get to see how how how it evolves and
and what developers and and different
folks do with
it uh if you could comment this might be
a bit of a very specific technical
question but llama 2 is incredible it's
the youve You released it recently um
there's already been a lot of exciting
developments around it is there what
what's your sense about its release and
is there llama 3 uh in the
future yeah I mean I think on on the
last podcast that we did together we
were talking about the debate that we
were having around open sourcing llama
too and I'm I'm glad that we did um you
know I think at this point there's the
the value of open- sourcing a foundation
model like llama 2 is significantly
greater than um than the than the risks
and in my view I mean we did we spent a
lot of time doing a very rigorous
assessment of that red teing it um but
I'm I'm I'm very glad that we released L
to I think the reception has been um
it's it's just been really exciting to
see how excited people have have been uh
about it and it's gotten way more you
know downloads and usage than I than I I
would have even expected and I was
pretty optimistic about it um so that's
that's been great um llama 3 uh I mean
there's always another model that we're
training so I mean it's you know for
right now you we built we train llama 2
and we released it as an open source
model and right now the priority is
building that into a bunch of the
consumer products all the different AIS
and um and and a bunch of different um
products that that we're basically
building as consumer products because
Lama 2 by itself it's not a consumer
product right it's more of a piece of
infrastructure that people could could
build things with so that's been the big
priority is kind of continuing to
fine-tune and um and and kind of just
get llama 2 and and its um and its
little the branches that we' built off
of it ready for Consumer products that
hopefully you know hundreds of millions
of people will will um enjoy using those
those products and billions one day but
yeah I mean we're also working on on the
Future Foundation models and um and I
don't have
anything new or news news on that I
don't know you I don't know exactly when
it's going to be ready
um I think just like we had a debate
around llama 2 and open sourcing it um I
think we'll we'll need to have a similar
debate and process to Red Team this and
make sure that this is safe but and my
hope is that we'll be able to to open
source this next version when it's ready
to but um but that's not that we're not
we're not you know close to doing that
this month I mean this is um that's just
it's a thing that we're we're still
somewhat early in working on well in
general thank you so much for open
sourcing llama to and for being being
transparent about all the exciting
developments around AI I feel like
that's contributing to really awesome
conversation about where we go with AI
and obviously it's really interesting to
see all the same kind of Technology
integrated into these personalized AI
systems uh with the with the AI personas
which I think when you put it in
people's hands and they get to have
conversations with these AI personas you
get to see like interesting failure cas
cases like where the things are dumb or
they go into weird directions or and we
get to learn as a society together
what's what's too far what's interesting
what's fun how how much personalization
is good how much generic is good we get
to learn all of this you probably don't
know this yourself like we have to all
figure it out by using it right yeah I
mean part of what we're trying to do
with the initial AI launch is um having
a diversity of different use cases just
so that people can try different things
because I don't know what's going to
work I mean are people going to like
playing the text based adventure games
or are they going to know like having a
comedian who who can add jokes um to to
threads or they can want to interact
with historical figures um you know we
made we made one of Jane Austin and and
one of Marcus Aurelius and I'm curious
to see how that goes um I'm excited for
both as a big fan I'm excited for both
to have conversations with them I mean
yeah that's you know
and I am also excited to see you know
the internet I don't know if you heard
can get kind of weird um and I applaud
them for it so I yeah it be it'd be nice
to see how weird they take it what kind
of memes I generated from this and I
think all of it is a especially in these
early stages of development as we
progress towards AGI it's good to learn
by by playing with those systems and
interacting with them at like a large
scale like you said yeah totally I mean
that's why well we're starting out with
a set and then um we're also working on
this platform that we call AI Studio
that's going to make it so that over
time anyone will be able to create one
of these AIS almost like they create any
other ugc content across the platform so
I'm I'm excited about that I think that
to some degree we're not going to see
the full potential of this until you
just have the full creativity of the
whole Community being able to build
stuff but there's a lot of a lot of
stuff that we need to get right so um so
I'm excited to take this in stages I
don't I don't think anyone out there is
really doing what we're doing here I
think that there are there are people
who are who are doing kind of like
fictional or consumer oriented character
type stuff but the extent to which we're
building it out with the um you know
avatars and expressiveness and and
making it so that they can interact
across um you know all the different
apps and um they'll help profiles and
you know we'll be able to engage people
on Instagram and Facebook I I I think
it's it's just it's um it's going to be
really fun well I'm still so we're
talking about AI but I'm still blown
away this entire time that I'm talking
to Mark Zuckerberg and you're not here
but you feel like you're here I've done
quite a few intimate conversations with
people alone in a room and this feels
like that so I keep forgetting for long
stretches of time that like we're not in
the same room and for me to imagine a
future where I can with a snap of a
finger do that with anyone in my life
the way we can just call right now and
have this kind of shallow 2D
experience uh to have this experience
like we're sitting next to each other
it's like I I don't I don't think I can
I don't think we can even imagine what
how that changes things where you can
immediately have intimate one-on-one
conversations with anyone that's that
might like in a way we might not even
predict change
civilization well I mean this is a lot
of the thesis behind the whole metaverse
is giving people the ability to feel
like you're present with someone I mean
this is like the main thing I talk about
all the time but I I do think that
there's a lot to to process about it I
mean from my perspective I mean I'm I'm
definitely here we're just not we're
we're not physically in the same place
it's not like you're you know you're not
talking to an AI right you're you know
this is um so I think the the thing
that's novel is the ability to convey
through technology a sense of almost
physical presence um so the the thing
that is not physically real is um is us
being in the same physical place but uh
but but kind of everything else is and I
think that that gets to this somewhat
philosophical question about what is the
nature of kind of the modern real world
and I I just think that that's it it
really is this combination of physical
world and the presence that we feel but
also being able to combine that with
this increasingly rich and powerful and
capable digital world that we have and
and and all of the The Innovation that's
getting created there so um I I think
it's super exciting because I mean the
the digital world is just is just
increasing um in in its capability and
our ability to do awesome things but the
physical world is so profound and that's
a lot of what makes us human is is that
we're we're physical beings so I don't
think we want to run away from that and
just spend all day on a screen and
that's like you know that's one of the
reasons why I care so much about about
helping to shape and accelerate the
these future Computing platforms I just
think this is so powerful and it's it's
you know even though the current version
of this is like you're wearing a headset
um I just think this is going to be by
far the most human and social Computing
platform that has ever existed and I
know that that's what what makes me
excited yeah I I think just to linger on
this kind of changing nature of reality
like of what is real maybe shifting it
towards the sort of Consciousness so
what is real is the subjective
experience of a thing that makes it feel
real versus necessarily being in the
same physical space cuz it feels like
we're in the same physical space yeah
and that the conscious experience of it
that's probably what is real not like
that the SpaceTime like the physics of
it like you're basically break breaking
physics and focusing on the
Consciousness that's what's real it's
whatever is going on inside my head but
there are a lot of Social and
psychological things that go along with
that experience that was previously only
physical presence right I think that
there's like an intimacy a trust um you
know there's a a level of communication
because so much of communication is
non-verbal and is based on Expressions
that you're kind of you you're you're
sharing with with someone when you're in
this kind of environment and before
those things would have only been
possible you know had you know I gotten
on a plane and and flown to Austin and
and sat you know physically with you in
the same place so I I think we're we're
basically shortcutting those laws of
physics and delivering the social and
psychological benefits of being able to
be present and and feel like you're
there with another person which I think
are real benefits um to anyone in the
world and I I think that that like you
said I I think that is going to be a
very profound thing um and that a lot of
that is that's the promise of of the
metaverse and what you know why you know
I I just why I think that that's the
next Frontier for for what we're working
on you know I started working on social
networks when they were primarily text
right the first version of Facebook your
profile you know you had one photo and
the rest of it was like lists of things
that you were interested in and and then
we kind of went through the period where
we were doing photos and you know we're
kind of in the period where most of the
content is video but there's a clear
Trend where you over time the way that
we want to express ourselves and and
kind of get insight and content about
the world around us gets increasingly
just richer and more Vivid and I I think
the ability to be immersed and feel
present with the people around you or
the people who you care about is from my
perspective clearly the next Frontier it
just so happens that it's inred
incredibly technologically difficult
right and requires building up these new
Computing platforms and completely new
software Stacks to deliver that but I
kind of feel like that's what we're here
to do as a
company well I really love the
connection you have through through
conversation and so for me this photo
realism is really really exciting I'm
I'm uh really excited for this future
and um thank you for building it thanks
to you and thanks to the amazing uh meta
teams that I've met uh the the engineers
and just everybody I've met here thank
you for helping to build this future and
uh thank you Mark for talking to me
inside the metaverse this is blowing my
mind I can't quite Express I would love
to measure my heart rate this whole time
would be hilarious if you're actually
like sitting in a Beach right now um I'm
not I'm in a conference room okay well
I'm in a beach and it if and not wearing
any pants I'm really sorry about that
for anyone else who's watching me in
physical space anyway thank you so much
for talking today this is this this
really blew my mind it's one of the most
incredible experiences of my life so
thank you for giving that to me awesome
awesome glad you got to check it out and
um it's always fun to talk all right
I'll catch you soon see you see you
later this is so so amazing
man this is so
amazing